we're learning more tonight about what
president-elect biden wants to do to
slow the spread of the coronavirus and
we are finding out there is one related
administration position
that is proving especially hard to fill
correspondent peter ducey
reports tonight from wilmington delaware
the president-elect began receiving
classified intel briefings this week but
still says the most pressing issue is
the pandemic
on the first day i'm inaugurated to say
i'm going to ask the public for 100 days
to mask just 100 days to mask not
forever 100 days
despite the focus on the virus biden
still hasn't revealed who he wants to
lead one critical department health and
human services
and now rhode island's governor gina
raimondo says
i am not going to be president-elect
biden's nominee
for hhs secretary my focus is right here
in rhode island
the newest chair of the democratic
governors association is upset about
biden insiders
leaking about her new mexico's governor
michelle lujan grisham who fox learned
turned down a nomination as secretary of
the interior complained to incoming
chief of staff ron claim today about
that getting out
according to the new york times there's
more job security
with dr fauci who began briefing biden
transition officials about covet today
i've been in this job for 36 years i
keep in the same job with
six administrations i totally fully
expect to be in this position
climate policy and economic policy will
be intertwined according to biden's pick
for director of the national economic
council brian deese
i will focus every day on the bold new
actions we need to take
to combat the climate crisis as the
president-elect continues filling out
his
own cabinet he plans to follow the lead
of three predecessors obama bush and
clinton
who plan to build public confidence in
the covet vaccine
do you plan to get vaccinated before
inauguration day and will you do it
in public the way that presidents obama
bush and clinton have suggested they're
willing i'd be happy to do that
the hairline fractures in the
president-elect's foot appear to be
healing his doctor had told us that he
would likely be in a walking
boot for several weeks and when we saw
him on tuesday he was in a big
walking boot but when we saw him today
he was in a slip-on
shoe with ankle support mike making
progress peter ducey live in wilmington
peter
thanks a lot